gotta get rid of these subjective words
like coercion consent manipulation it's
like those are all subjective like if I
if I am dating a guy and he convinces me
to go to cam work in Romania is that
coercion or a good salesman you know
what I mean and this is this is what I
it's like when we get to all these
subjectivity no rape is forced sex
that's it all of these other oh
no or sex either he forced you to have
sex or he didn't and I think when we get
in the weeds of all this whining and
complaining and accusing men of thinking
doing things they didn't do I think it's
very confusing for the women and I think
it's and it's very confusing for society
because now we don't know the difference
between a woman that actually was raped
and a woman that is just crying